je suis pédiatre et je me suis toujours
demandé comment faire pour que les
enfants s'épanouissent pour qu'il soit
heureux de vivre
sociable entreprenants un jour j'ai tiré
un fil et j'ai découvert les dernières
recherches sur le cerveau émotionnel de
l'enfant ces recherches nous disent
comment faire pour que les relations que
les adultes ont avec leurs enfants et
comment ces relations transforme en
profondeur le cerveau de l'enfant et
agissent sur ce qu'ils sont et vont
devenir ses connaissances m'ont
réellement scotch et quand je les ai
découverts et c'est pour ça que j'ai eu
envie de les partager mon métier de
pédiatre m'a amené à des rencontres et
beaucoup beaucoup de parents des
milliers de parents souvent désemparés
inquiet vis-à-vis d'éducation comment
faire pour que mon enfant soit quelqu'un
de bien réussi au 20e siècle
je leur répondais de façon intuitive moi
de mon point de vue je pense que telle
ou telle attitude les aiderait
actuellement grâce aux recherches
scientifiques qui sont faites dans le
monde entier en suède aux états unis en
chine
j'ai des éléments pour leur répondre
comment cela a commencé un jour je
rentre dans la chambre d'une mère qui
vient d'accoucher et je vois que cette
mère de sept enfants ont l'air
particulièrement heureux détendu sera
jeudi à cette femme
ça a l'air de bien se passer avec la
transfo elle me dit oui c'est normal
comment ça c'est normal et elle me dit
mon compagnon et moi nous avons beaucoup
beaucoup câliner notre bébé pendant la
grossesse
ensuite pendant mes consultations très
souvent j'entends les parents dire à
leurs enfants
ah tiens toi tranquille d'insupportable
tu fais n'importe quoi il là je vois un
enfant qui se ratatine ou bien qui
devient agité donc sous mes yeux
j'ai pu constater que les relations que
les parents ont avec leurs enfants
transforme vraiment leur comportement
cela évidemment interrogé
je me suis dit mais est ce qu'on sait
pourquoi et comment les relations que
nous avons avec l'enfant transforme à ce
point sa façon d'être et bien ce sont
les neurosciences affective et sociale
qui m'ont donné la réponse c'est
sciences sont très récente elle date
environ de 15 ans elle étudie ce qui se
passe au niveau du cerveau quand nous
sommes en relation avec les autres que
nous éprouvons des émotions et des
sentiments
en france on connaît bien les
neurosciences cognitives qui s'occupe de
tout ce qui est intellectuel au niveau
du cerveau mais c'est neuro sciences
affectives sont moins bien connues elles
nous disent que toute rencontre
toute expérience émotionnelle transforme
en profondeur le cerveau et de façon
globale aussi bien le cerveau affectif
et le cerveau intellectuelle est que
plus l'enfant est jeune plus le cerveau
est malléable et modifiables maintenant
je vous propose d'imaginer avec roy la
vie d'un enfant et de voir qu'est ce qui
se passe dans son cerveau alors lucas à
trois mois il est dans son lit et il
pleure il appelle ses parents et ses
parents hésitent
est ce qu'il faut aller le voir est ce
qu'il faut le laisser pleurer lucas lui
il ne peut pas s'apaiser seul et
pourquoi il peut pas s'apaiser seul
parce que son cerveau est immature son
cortex préfrontal qui est ici n'est pas
capable de gérer ses émotions il ne peut
pas se dire oui je suis seul je suis
inquiet mais mes parents sont occupées
c'est pas grave je vais m'apaiser nous
il est pas capable de faire ça parce que
son cerveau est immature
si les parents ne répondent pas à ces
pleurs et bien dans son cerveau des
molécules de stress vont à être sécrétée
du cortisol et ce cortisol s'il est en
trop grande quantité et de façon
prolongée il peut détruire des cellules
cérébrales dans des zones très
importante dont ce fameux cortex
préfrontal
au contraire si les parents mattern
lucas le câline le console et bien c'est
extraordinaire ça fait maturer son
cerveau et ça fait maturer le cortex
préfrontal mais aussi l'hippocampe qui
est une structure cérébrale qui nous
permet de mémoriser d'apprendre le
materner ça fait aussi sécréter une
molécule qui s'appelle le bdnf et qui
permet aux cellules cérébrales de bien
se développer et d'avoir de bonnes
connexions
ça fait sécréter aussi une molécule que
vous connaissez probablement qui est
l'ocytocine qui nous permet d'être plus
empathique être moins stressé
bref ce maternage agit surtout le
système nerveux nous rend plus apaisée
nous des stress et nous permettent de
gérer nos émotions
donc vous voyez bien que actuellement
les chercheurs peuvent voir beaucoup
mieux ce qui se passe au niveau du
cerveau et voit en détail ce qui se
passe et ils nous disent que toute
rencontre tous tes expériences
émotionnelles va modifier en profondeur
le cerveau va modifier les structures
cérébrales les circuits cérébraux les
cellules cérébrales même les molécules
cérébrale et même l'expression de
certains gènes et ils nous disent que le
cerveau de l'enfant est très fragile et
très malléable et très modifiable
maintenant lucas à deux ans il est à la
crèche et aujourd'hui il a mordu tom
parce que tom lui a pris sa tétine
pourquoi morte il est bien parce que son
cerveau est immature il est débordé et
dominé par son cerveau émotionnel c'est
à dire qu'il est extrêmement en colère
c'est des tempêtes émotionnel quand il
est triste ce sont des très grands
chagrins quand il a peur ce sont des
très grande panique donc
l'enfant n'est pas caractériel ce ne
sont pas des caprices
l'enfant n'est pas les tyrans nous ce
comportement là est juste dû à
l'immaturité de son cerveau son cerveau
archaïque
domine également alors c'est quoi le
savoir car nous l'avons tous au fond de
notre cerveau il est là pour notre
survie des pneus nous sentons en grand
danger
soit nous attaquons soigne fillon soit
nous est nous sommes sidérés et bien
lucas lui il était en une grande
insécurité
il a mordu ce n'est pas parce qu'il est
méchant c'est parce que son cerveau est
immature
donc c'est extrêmement important de
savoir ça et l'attitude des adultes face
au comportement de l'enfant qui
déroutent beaucoup d'adultes va être
capital pour le développement du cerveau
d'enfant et pour le développement de
l'enfant
si les parents de luca le dévalorise ou
le punissant disant t'es pas gentil
c'est pas bien ce que tu as fait d'avoir
mordu et bien dans ce cas là cela
stresse lucas et ça empêche le cerveau
de mature elle est donc son cortex
préfrontal va continuer à ne pas être
mature et donc il va toujours être
dominé par ces impulsions et ses
émotions à un âge où ils devraient être
raisonnables c'est à dire vers 5-6 ans
si les adultes gifle lucas vous imaginez
que c'est pas bon non plus pour le
cerveau donc toutes les humiliations
qu'elle soit verbale ou physique
entravent le développement du cerveau de
l'enfant
il y actuellement des centaines d'études
sur l'effet des gifles et des fessées en
transe est considéré comme anodin
eh bien ces études nous disent que ça
donne des troubles du comportement chez
l'enfant
les enfants deviennent agressifs anxieux
déprimé et l'adulte qu'ils deviendront
l'adolescent aussi qu'ils deviendront
pourront avoir des comportements
violents et être addict à l'alcool et
aux drogues
rebecca wadler de l'université d'oxford
a fait le bilan de 30 étude sur les
éducations punitive est sévère elle en
conclut quoi que contrairement à ce que
les adultes souhaiterait ça ne fait pas
du tout progressé les enfants au
contraire
les enfants et les adolescents
deviennent durs insensible non
empathique violent et ils ont des
attitudes anti sociale volet drogue
donc quand on sait tout ça par contre
excusez-moi si les parents comprennent
l'enfant comprenne ce qu'il ressent et
par exemple les parents de luca vont
dire à l'enfant
je comprends que ce soit en colère mais
on ne meurt pas par contre je te fais
confiance en grade et en grandissant tu
vas apprendre plus mornes et bien ça et
ça c'est extraordinaire ça fait mature
elle cerveau et dans ce cas là
lucas en grandissant et bien il ne sera
plus soumis à son cerveau émotionnel et
à ses impulsions l'attitude
bienveillante qui est donc prôné par
tous ces recherches ne veut pas dire
qu'on laisse tout faire à l'enfant pas
du tout l'adulte transmet des valeurs il
met un cadre il pose des limites mais il
le fait avec bienveillance
quand on sait tout ça que le cerveau de
l'enfant est très fragile qu'il faut en
prendre soin on peut plus continuer à
faire comme on fait jusqu'à maintenant
comment changer notre façon d'être avec
les enfants est ce que c'est possible
d'abord oui c'est possible parce que
notre cerveau même à nous adultes
il est malléable et modifiables donc on
peut changer notre façon de penser et
d'agir
est-ce que c'est facile non c'est pas
facile ça va demander du temps et
pourquoi parce que la bonne éducation
dans le monde entier et depuis des
millénaires c'est de croire que en
faisant souffrir les enfants ils vont
progresser
donc il faut un changement total de la
façon de considérer les enfants de toute
la société
les éducateurs des enseignants et des
parents mais de toute la société
qu'est ce qui peut nous aider et bien
maintenant on a l'information c'est la
bienveillance et l'empathie qui fait
naturel cerveau d'enfant l'empathie
c'est quoi c'est être à l'écouté de
l'enfant sentir
prendre ses émotions donc il faut
vraiment se mettre à la place de
l'enfant
imaginez que vous adultes vous avez
passé une journée stressante
vous en avez ras le bol vous rentrez
chez vous et vous vous mettez à pleurer
et votre conjoint vous dis j'en ai marre
de tes comédie tes caprices va dans
t'acharnes et bien vous seriez très en
colère contre votre conjoint et je pense
que votre relation avec lui en prendrait
un sacré coup et bien quand vous faites
ça votre enfant l'enfant ressent la même
chose mais en beaucoup plus important
puisque l'huile ne sait pas gérer ses
émotions
l'empathie nous l'avons en nous dès la
naissance
elle se développe à chaque fois que nous
rencontrons des personnes bienveillantes
et empathique
si un cercle vertueux vous quand vous
êtes en pratique avec votre enfant
le cortex orbitofrontal qui est ici
s'activent nous permet être empathique
de l'ocytocine est sécrétée qui nous
permet d'être empathique et l' inverse
c'est vrai quand on n'est pas en
pratique avec l'enfant quand on
l'humilie ça inhibe tout ce qui nous
permet d'être empathique donc maintenant
nous savons ce qu'il faudrait faire
l'attitude bienveillante et empathique
fait développer le cerveau de l'enfant
les rendent heureux sociable coopérants
curieux enthousiastes et c'est qualité
persiste à l'âge adulte
donc je pense que si tous les acteurs de
la petite enfance et de l'enfance et de
l'adolescence éducateurs enseignants
parents grands-parents toute la société
avait cette attitude empathique et
bienveillante avec les enfants je pense
vraiment et j'y crois totalement le
monde serait plus pacifique et plus
chaleureux